hey christina hi
how are you
you're good
all right
you know not the happiest
material to be talking about in the
morning so thank you for talking to me
about this
i'm curious i mean this story is
heartbreaking it's tragic it made me
want to scream multiple times when i was
watching it
what was it about this project that made
you want to tell that story and did you
know
how much this was going to be a
frustrating story when you started
telling it
i feel you
on that sentiment that it's very
frustrating to watch this story unfold
um
and i think that
you know with a story like this which is
based in truth
that it's really important to key into
that discomfort that we feel when we
watch stories like this
because ultimately you know this is
holding up a mirror
to ourselves especially as americans to
look into this mirror to this story and
say what are we not doing right where
have we gone wrong
um and and really coming to terms with
that discomfort and realizing that not
only you know is this a story about
systemic issues
that are very deep and have a long
history but also
there's people behind all of these
issues there's a humanity at stake
and i think that's what the story does
so well is that it really gets into the
lives of these
characters who are based on real people
and their struggles and their tragedies
and um
i think that's what danny did so
beautifully is you know depict these
stories and the real lives of these of
these people
100
i would
i would echo that i didn't know um a
great deal about the um opioid epidemic
in in america but it was a
subject matter that i was kind of
vaguely aware of and sort of intrigued
by and concerned by certainly um you
know seeing um
that the
facts were reflecting um you know a a
growing issue as opposed to one that was
seemingly kind of being um dealt with
and addressed adequately and then when
dope sick came along i think um
as
you know pippa pointed out it was uh
comforting to see something that you
know was was based in truth but through
the kind of dramatization was actually
humanizing the story making it more kind
of understandable and accessible
and
explaining that
you know um it was as you said
it's down to um human error and and
people making um these kind of
problematic decisions in positions of
power to take advantage of
of uh hard-working american citizens
so it was it was a story that felt like
it really needed to be told because at
its core it's a story about social
injustice and about drawing people's
attention to exactly how how america
kind of got to this place and and um you
know who needs to be held accountable
and furthermore also you know
where people who ought not to have been
vilified have been vilified you know the
victims of
uh opioid addiction have been uh in in
many regards made the
villains in in the story for far too
long and i think dopesick seeks to
address that and and cause correct the
narrative
how do you approach these characters how
do you approach
humanizing individuals who
really are helping to ruin the lives of
so many people i mean i know actors talk
about you know how they have to be the
ones that like their character but do
you start from a place of liking your
character when your character is doing
things like this
i always start from a place of what do i
know
um and sometimes that's in the text and
sometimes you know that's my
responsibility to sort of
you know imagine what that would be for
myself especially since i
don't play a character based off of a
real person
um
but i certainly think that there are
many people who have been in a similar
position to amber
and um yeah like i think ultimately what
it comes down to is what is at stake
here what do i know about where i'm
coming from what i want
and what is in my way of getting that
and how do i get it
um and you know getting to work on
incredible writing like this it you know
makes it really easy to explore those
really important questions
yeah i think um
there was some like interesting um kind
of you know creative space to operate in
because uh like um
pippa's character amber like you know
billy is also kind of an amalgam a
composite
of uh several different people who you
know um
i think
would have likely kind of worked in
similar roles for purdue
so um i wasn't tied down in any way
there was an opportunity to kind of
interpret what danny had written but so
much of
what makes billy was already on the page
and um it was really intriguing to me to
see kind of a young person i think go
into this with you know initially sort
of honest intentions but um get caught
up in what was quite clearly a very
problematic work culture at purdue where
they were being incentivized to you know
go against what was
objectively the correct and moral thing
to do um in pursuit of financial success
and uh you know in an effort to kind of
climb the corporate ladder um
and so you know without getting into
spoiler territory or giving too much
away um
you know i think
for me personally getting to
explore that over you know the arc of a
season and and wrestle with those um
moral questions throughout was uh
a really great opportunity and key to
humanizing the character in the way that
you know we kind of touched on before
well what was it like to explore that
dynamic between billy and dr fenix and
what was it like to
have the experience of working with
michael keaton because some of your
scenes are so interesting together i
mean they sort of almost develop like a
father-son relationship but he's
still manipulating him the whole time
yeah
yeah that was that was i i think the the
phoenix billy relationship is kind of
key to i think um the success and the
enjoyment that billy feels initially you
know in the role but also the kind of um
i think i think a big contributor to the
kind of um
uh moral difficulties that he sort of
faces along the way because he does grow
so close to phoenix and he does um
obviously
you know become increasingly aware of um
how kind of
uh disingenuous their relationship you
know uh is the further the further they
they they go
um
and i mean for me to work with michael
keaton was obviously uh you know
a bit of a dream come true like he's uh
he's phenomenal and i was so lucky to
have so many scenes with him um and yeah
i mean you know the the billy phoenix
relationship does um model a kind of
father-son relationship i think in my
mind billy probably belonged to a family
of like you know um really exceptional
academics and always felt an insecurity
about the fact that he didn't quite
belong and his skills were more in kind
of you know
i guess as a salesman you know simply
put um and in phoenix he found someone
who you know also was very good at
talking to people you know and making
people feel comfortable and so uh i
think yeah billy arguably is sort of
closer to phoenix and he probably is his
own like father to my mind and me and
danny being the writer like we we
clicked over that as a concept and kind
of ran with it a little bit
amber is somebody who definitely is
blunt she's pretty frank about some of
the things she says is there something
fun and freeing in playing a woman like
her who really does say what she wants
to people
absolutely
i just loved from the beginning that
amber really just had
uh
like no there's no filter
her can i swear in this her
bs meter was like super like
sensitive she could like read you like
nobody else and i think
for me just based on you know roles that
i've previously played it was really fun
to play someone that um
wasn't necessarily like the nicest
person but definitely a person with a
beating heart um maybe it's a little
harder for her to access that beating
heart he tries
um but you know she's flawed but that's
that's always fun to play
how hard is it to become invested in
this story and have a hand in telling
this knowing that there's still no
resolution for all of these lives and
families that have been affected and
have been destroyed by this
when you tell a real life story like
that that doesn't have a happy ending or
really sort of any ending is it hard to
have that weigh on you is it hard to let
that go does it just is it just sort of
something you kind of have to close a
book on when you're done
um
kind of kind of hard to say because as
you as you say you know the uh the issue
is so um widespread and and far from uh
reaching its conclusion and in many ways
you know the victims of vocaloid
addiction um have suffered kind of
irreparable damage and and i don't think
we're under any illusions about how much
the show you know being ultimately a
piece of entertainment can can go
towards sort of repairing some of that
damage i think you know
the hope is that we're able to stimulate
conversation around the the damages
caused by opioid addiction
that this um brings attention to the
kind of social action and political work
that's that's being done to try and um
address some of that damage and
you know where uh reparations and
compensations can can be made
um you know we hope that
the show will kind of
just just draw more attention to that
and and you know make folks more aware
um
uh and you know when you when you
involve yourself in projects that do
have these kind of
social applications um i think
it's hard not to feel uh a sort of
connection to the to the cause that goes
beyond you know when you call a rap um
this has certainly woken me up to a lot
of things about um addiction and and the
opioid crisis specifically that formerly
i wasn't as aware of so i do want to
continue to try and find some some way
of participating in that space um you
know after after dopesick
comes out
yeah i think it's certainly it's a piece
that lends itself to
starting a conversation to just be the
beginning of the kinds of questions that
we should be asking and uh answers that
we should be seeking in our own lives
and our own communities
well i appreciate you talking to me
about it you're both terrific in this
everyone is and it's it's just it's
it's frustrating to watch but well done
so thank you
thank you thank you together
yes thanks a lot
you